[Music]
the
tashi to the west north or northwest of
shenzhou at a very great distance from
it so that the foreign ships find it
difficult
to make the voyage there directly after
these ships have left shenzhou
they come in some 40 days to lan lee
where they trade
the following year they go out to sea
again when with the aid of the regular
wind they take some 60 days to make the
journeys
the products of this country are for the
most part brought to san futsi
where they are sold to merchants who
forward them to china
this country of the tashi is powerful
and
warlike its extent is very great and its
inhabitants are
preeminent among all foreigners for
their distinguished
bearings the climate throughout a large
part of it
is cold snow falling for a depth of two
or three feet
consequently rugs are much prized
the king the officials and all the
people serve or
revere heaven they've also a buddha by
the name of mahya
wu every seven days they cut their hair
and clip their fingernails
at the new year for a whole month they
fast and chant prayers
daily they pray to heaven five times
the country of makkya is reached if one
travels from the country of
malopa for eighty days westward by land
this is the place where the buddha
mahaya wu was born
in the house of the buddha the walls are
made of jade stone of
every colour every year when the
anniversary of the death of the buddha
comes round
the people from all the countries of the
tar she assemble
here when they vie with each other in
bringing presence of gold
silver jewels and precious stones
then also is the house adorned anew with
silk brocade
further off there is the tomb of the
buddha continually by day and night
there is at this place such a
brilliant refulgance that no one can
approach it
he who does loses his sight
whosoever in his hour of death rubs his
breast with dirt
taken from this tomb will they say be
restored to life again
by the power of the buddha
this video is sponsored by skillshare
the online learning platform
skillshare is a great resource i've been
using to hone my video making skills and
prepare for bigger projects
in the future one great example of a fun
course
is how to make dope low budget films by
julian clepper
a fun dynamic course that's both
educational and
inspirational and has given my brother
and i a lot of ideas for the future
and that's skillshare whether you're a
professional or just starting out it's a
great resource for self-improvement
and a great place to spark ideas and to
start you off the first thousand of my
subscribers to click the link in the
description we'll get a free trial of
premium membership
so you can explore your creativity and
make the most
of 2021 thanks
this people were originally a branch of
the persians
in the ta'yi period of the sui dynasty
there lived a high-minded and
wise man among the persians who found
deep down
in a hole a stone bearing an inscription
and this he took for a good omen so he
called the people together
took by force the things necessary for
arming men
and enrolled followers who gradually
increased in number
till he became powerful enough to make
himself
king and then he took possession of the
western portion of poor sea
since the yonghui period of the tang
dynasty
the ta'shi have come repeatedly to our
court to present
tribute before the time of their king
ponni mohuan
they were called white robed tashi
after apollo they were called
black robed tashi
the capital of the country called
missouli is an important center for the
trade
of foreign peoples the king wears a
turban
of silk brocade and foreign cotton stuff
on each new moon and full moon
he puts on an eight-sided flat-topped
headdress
of pure gold set with the most precious
jewels in the world
his robe is of silk brocade and is bound
around him with a jade girdle on his
feet
he wears golden shoes in his residence
the pillars
are of cornethians stone the walls of
lachanze stone
the king's throne is set with pearls and
precious stones and the steps of the
throne are covered with pure gold
the various vessels and utensils around
the throner of gold
and silver and precious pearls are
knotted in the screen behind it
in great court ceremonies the king sits
behind the screen
and on the other side protecting him the
ministers of state
surround him bearing golden bucklers and
helmets
and armed with precious swords his other
officers are called
tai wei each of them has the command of
some twenty thousand horsemen the horses
are seven foot high
and are shot with iron his army is brave
and excels in all military exercises
the streets of the capital are more than
50 feet broad
in the middle is a roadway 20 feet broad
and 4 foot high for the use of camels
horses and even carrying goods about on
either side for the convenience of
pedestrians business
there are sidewalks paved with green and
black
or bluish black flagstones of surpassing
beauty the dwellings of the people are
like those of the chinese
with this difference that here thin
flagstones are used instead of tiles
the food consists of rice and other
cereals muttons stewed with fine strips
of dough is considered
a delicacy the poor live on fish
vegetables and fruits only
sweet dishes are preferred to sour wine
is made out of the juice of grapes
and there is also a drink called sea a
decoction of sugar and spices
by mixing of honey and spices they make
a drink called
mei si tahua which is very heating
very rich persons use a measure instead
of scales and business transactions in
gold or silver
the markets are noisy and bustling and
are filled with great store of gold and
silver damasks brocades and
such like wares the artisans have true
artistic spirit
the country of okanto belongs to wu si
li
according to tradition in olden times a
stranger
su corny by name built on the shore of
the sea a great
tower under which the earth was dug out
and two rooms were made
well connected and very well secreted in
one volt was grain in the other
were arms the tower was 200
chang high four horses abreast could
ascend to two-thirds of its height
in the center of the building was a
great well connecting
with the big river to protect it from
surprise by troops of other lands
the whole country guarded the tower that
warded off the foes
in the upper and lower parts of it
twenty thousand men could readily be
stationed to guard
or to sally forth to fight on the summit
there was a wondrous great mirror
if warships of other countries made a
sudden attack the mirror detected them
beforehand
and the troops were ready in time for
duty in recent years there came to
oconto a foreigner
who asked to be given work in the guard
house of the tower he was employed to
sprinkle
and sweep for years no one entertained
any suspicion of him
when suddenly one day he found an
opportunity to steal the mirror
and throw it into the sea after which he
ran
off
[Music]
the country of paita is the great
metropolis of all the countries of the
tashi
travelling by land from malo par one
comes to it after about 130 days journey
passing on the way some 50 cities the
country is extremely powerful and
large and the number of its foot
soldiers and cavalry
armed and equipped is very great the
king is a direct successor of the buddha
mahiawu
and the throne has down to the present
time been transmitted through 29
generations
covering a period of from six to seven
hundred years
the other lands of the tashi have waged
war against each other
but no one has dared to invade this
country
when the king appears in public a black
umbrella is carried over him and on the
top is a jade lion
with a golden moon on its back shining
like a star
and visible from far off town and
markets are cut by well-made streets
and the people live lavishly there is
great store of precious things and of
satins
there is a little rice fish and
vegetables the people eat cakes meat
and butter the products of the country
are gold and silver
engraved glassware of the finest quality
white cloth and liquid storax
the inhabitants like to wear turbans and
clothes of fine snow white cotton
every seven days they cut their hair and
nails and five times daily they pray or
worship heaven they profess the religion
of the ta'shi
as they are the descendants of the
buddha the people of other countries
come thither to do them honor
the country of a young man resembles wu
pa
as regards inhabitants and the products
of the soil the chief of the country
wears a turban
wraps himself in light silk but wears no
garments and goes barefooted his
servants wear no headdress and go
barefooted but they wrap themselves in
sarongs so the body is covered they live
on meal cakes mutton
sheep's milk fish and vegetables the
soil produces
dates in large quantities along the
coast
pearls are found and in the mountains
horse raising is carried on
on a large scale the other countries
which trade here purchase horses pearls
and dates
which they get in exchange for cloves
cardamom seeds and campfour
the country of mulan pea is to the west
of the tashi country
there is a great sea and to the west of
the sea there are countless countries
but mulan pea is the one country which
is visited by the big ships of the tashi
putting to sea from topanti in the
country of the taji
after sailing due west for full 100 days
one reaches this country a single one of
the big ships of these
carries several thousand men and on
board they have stores of wine and
provisions
as well as weaving looms if one speaks
of big ships
there are none so big as those of mulan
p
the products of the country are
extraordinary the grains of wheat to
three inches long
the melons six feet round if one travels
by land from moulin p
200 days journey the days are only six
hours long in autumn if the west wind
arises
men and beasts must at once drink to
keep alive
and if they are not quick enough about
it they die of thirst
the country of sikhali yea is near the
frontier
of lu may it is an island of the sea
a thousand li in breadth the clothing
customs and language of the people
are the same as those in lou may the
country has a mountain with a cavern of
great depth in it
when seen from afar it is smoke in the
morning and fire
in the evening when seen at a short
distance it is a madly
roaring fire when the people of the
country carry up on a pole the big stone
weighing 500 or a thousand catties and
throw it down into the cavern
after a little while there is an
explosion and the stone comes out in
pieces
like punish stone once in every five
years fire and stones break out and flow
down as far as the sea coast
and then go back again the trees in the
woods through which this stream flows
are not burnt
but the stones it meets in its course
are turned
to ashes
the country of pipa lo contains four
cities
the inhabitants pray to heaven not to
the buddha
the land produces many camels and sheep
and the people feed themselves with the
flesh and milk of camels and with baked
cakes
the country brings forth the so-called
camel crane
which measures from the ground to its
crown six to seven feet
it has wings and can fly but not to any
great height
there is also in this country a wild
animal called thula
it resembles a camel in shape and ox in
size
and is of a yellow colour its four legs
are five feet long
its hind legs only three feet its head
is
high up and turned upwards its skin
is an inch thick there is also in this
country a kind of mule with
brown white and black stripes around its
body
these animals wonder about the mountain
wilds they are a
variety of the camel the inhabitants of
this country
who are great huntsmen hunt these
animals with poisoned arrows
you